welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and wolverine is now confirmed to
exist in the mcu with a strategically
snicked easter egg in she-hulk episode 2
reporting man fights with metal claws
and bar brawl hey come on where's the
music man fights with metal claws and
barbra
hey yes thank you considering this
reveal comes right between marvel
studios revealing its first mcu mutant
in kamala khan and we expect some
announcements about mutants at d23 this
was no random egg fart while it takes
the form of a headline you might read
about my home state of florida and a
slow news day topic at that bar fight
with metal claws that's it unless it was
the governor at the china section of
epcot bumping to page 12. this detail
nonetheless establishes the existence of
wolverine and perhaps other x-men in the
mcu already while also giving us some
insight of where marvel studios is at
with their origin timeline and therefore
how marvel plans to introduce the x-men
to this universe since disney reacquired
the film rights to the x-men in recent
years and since the abrupt killing off
of patrick stewart's charles xavier in
multiverse madness indicating marvel
studios is more likely to reboot its
mutants with new actors in the mcu the
central question of the mutant's new mcu
origin has been have the mutants always
existed in the mcu just hidden from us
or did some recent events spawn them
into existence and i suppose a related
question would be did wolverine and
captain america fight together in world
war ii and if so did logan know who cap
was fine kamala khan was established as
an enhanced individual with a genetic
predisposition that bruno called a
mutation and marvel studios baptized
this as a mutant confirmation with ron
wasserman's x-men theme
but this headline about a man with metal
claws in a bar fight is clearly a nod to
the first fox x-men film in 2000 in
which logan participated in cage fights
in a bar in alberta canada and then
afterwards a bitter dude threatens him
with a knife so logan sneaks his claws
at this dude's neck and then for good
measure slices the bartender shotgun now
i doubt this headline in she-hulk is
referencing that specific scene as
something that happened in the mcu
continuity hugh jackman will probably
not be the 616 emcu's primary wolverine
he may cameo as wolverine from another
universe like 838 hopefully in a future
crossover event like secret wars but
really wolverine in any universe has a
habit of getting into bart fights the
dude was even ready to take a swing at
charles and magneto in x-men first class
excuse me i'm eric lynch xavier go
yourself but the fact that the headline
did not call the man wolverine or call
him a mutant suggests that wolverine is
not yet a known figure not yet a member
of the x-men still a lone wanderer who
might not even realize that what he is
is a mutant this also indicates that
mutants in x-men currently in the mcu
are still in their infancy as a class of
superheroes so why only now are mutants
spawning kamala khan always had that
genetic condition but she needed a
conditional event to activate and unlock
those powers in her case it was the
bengal we think a form of cretek that
emits a kind of cosmic radiation the
popular theory is that something similar
has happened recently to activate
dormant mutants throughout the 616
universe specifically the universe-wide
release of cosmic radiation in the form
of the snapping of the infinity stones
which technically remember occurred four
times i do see the logic of this
explanation and it would explain why we
haven't seen mutants until now but the
issue i can't get around is that this
would deprive these mutant characters or
some of the most interesting things
about them from the comics their
histories eric lyncher magneto is a
holocaust survivor that trauma left him
with a lifelong hatred towards humanity
and the evil humanity is capable of when
its bigotry goes unchecked now the
present year of the mcu is 2025. so for
the mcu magneto to be a holocaust
survivor he would have to be in his 80s
at least that would limit what kind of
stories they could really tell with
magneto like they could pull an x-men
first class and do a story set in an
earlier decade with eric and charles's
younger men but if they wanted to do a
present day magneto story they would
either have to settle for an
octogenarian villain which isn't the
worst thing in the world he could still
be 80 and fit or maybe they could use
the quantum realm or king timeline
meddling to justify how magneto could be
in the present day without being super
old maybe they could cross over a
younger magneto from another universe
but in that case would this magneto have
the same history with the 616 charles
and all the other characters see it's
just kind of a mess now marvel studios
could retcon magneto's origins so that
he is a survivor of some other more
recent war crime or humanitarian crisis
but
i don't know i would not want to begin
speculating which dark chapters in human
history are comparable enough to the
holocaust to permit appropriating them
for magneto's origin really an even
trickier example for the mcu is
wolverine now you might notice that when
we make these videos there's a little
bit more that goes into it than just
flipping on a webcam new rockstars is a
whole team of editors that makes our
stuff look slick
after it's been recorded but not
everybody has a team like that if you've
ever wanted to start making content of
your own but you haven't because you
don't have an editor well edited is here
to help with edit.tv you can hire an
editor that specifically understands how
to edit for youtube on their homepage
you'll find a leaderboard designed to
provide the best freelancers for the
content you want to make you can rate
and review your editor to help boost
their position on the website or find
editor reviews to find the one that's
just right for you or hey maybe you
already know how to edit and you want to
sign up to edit videos for other
creators well edited's got you covered
there too you can build a profile set
your rates and you'll be editing in no
time and if you're going to be making a
lot of content edit it as a premium
service for 25 dollars a month it'll get
you unlimited orders on the website and
no transaction fees so go for it get
that theory video you've been noodling
on out of your head and onto the web all
you gotta do is check out edit.tv to
learn how to make youtube videos without
knowing how to edit wolverine's mutation
is not adamantium clause of course his
mutation is regeneration and bone claws
that protrude from his knuckles his
adamantium skeleton came from the us
government trying to replicate the
proto-adamantium from captain america's
shield in the weapon plus program a
subdivision of that was weapon x x
referring to the roman numeral 10 logan
being the tenth experiment after weapon
one that being steve rogers so weapon x
kidnapped the regenerative mutant super
soldier from the black ops unit team x
logan and fused adamantium to his
skeleton surgically therefore
wolverine's history is inextricably
linked with the history of captain
america in the super soldier program and
now with wolverine in the mcu marvel has
a great opportunity to explore another
dark side of the super soldier program
wild cap was in the ice throughout the
20th century like what we saw with bucky
and hydra or isaiah bradley and the
torturous experience he went through or
even one could argue bruce banner and
emil blonsky now we meet another super
soldier left with scars one suffering
from amnesia and one who is canadian but
the fact that this headline says metal
claws strongly indicates that wolverine
likely existed before the snap because
he would have needed time for weapon x
to find him and to operate on him
otherwise the recent burst of cosmic
radiation would have had to first
activate his regenerative powers and a
team of scientists with liquid
adamantium would have had to operate on
him and he would have had to escape all
within the past few years and in this
version wolverine wouldn't have been the
awesome forever soldier who fought in
several wars throughout us history this
kind of shoehorned rush origin i guess
is possible it just limits marvel
studios in a way that they've never
limited themselves before in a way that
they definitely do not have to do now
marvel studios has again and again
signaled that they want to move past the
blitz and not focus their stories
setting them during those five years
therefore while i still believe some
energy based activation was necessary to
awaken mutants in the mcu i don't think
the snap was the sole inciting incident
i think over the decades in fact over
the centuries over the millennia several
individuals with mutant genes have
gotten activated by cosmic influences
like creed tech like the ten rings or
the bengals or maybe someone else
fumbled the tesseract at some point in
history leading to a small number of
mutants beginning to emerge throughout
the 20th century existing unbeknownst to
the wider population and then recent
events with the snaps woke up a lot more
of them this way marvel could establish
not just wolverine but other older
mutants like nathaniel essex mr sinister
apocalypse all these old-timers existing
in the past of 616. kevin feige got his
start as an associate producer on the
set of that 2000 box x-men film that
she-hulk just referenced he was the nerd
in the room with the best instincts of
what elements of superheroes need to be
prioritized in films i think our man
knows the essential parts of magneto and
wolverine are their dark histories from
the wars of the 20th century and yeah
who wouldn't want to establish that
steve rogers and logan could have
crossed paths in world war ii and for no
other reason than to just show logan
seeing cat marching past with the 107th
logan taking out his cigar and grunting
that pup
follow me on tick tock instagram and
twitter
and subscribe to the rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you